thank you to LastPass for sponsoring a
portion of this video hey everyone how's
it going my name is Mei Yuko and welcome
back to my channel where we talk about
tech career and life so today we're
gonna talk again about coding boot camps
for those of you who are unfamiliar you
may ask what are coding boot camps
coding boot camps are shortened
intensive programs to learn software
engineering skills with the ultimate
goal of getting a job they're a great
accelerated way to get into software
engineering without needing to go
through a four-year degree program at a
university they vary in duration but
typically are around 12 weeks long and
spans about 40 to 60 hours a week of
work that was from a previous video
where I talk about what coding boot
camps are if you haven't watched it
already I'll leave a link in the card
right above so today we're specifically
gonna be talking about how to choose a
coding boot camp decided to go to one is
already a big life decision so choosing
which one to attend is a huge first step
and there's a lot of things to consider
I've actually never gone through the
experience myself so I interviewed a few
people who did to give insight on the
important factors to consider when
choosing a boot camp and before we dive
right in I wanted to say thank you to
LastPass for sponsoring this portion of
the video so I hope we all know that in
order to peruse the Internet in a safe
and secure way you're supposed to use
different passwords for every single
site that you log into well LastPass
relieves a burden of generating and
remembering those passwords with
LastPass you don't have to write
remember or reset passwords LastPass
also auto fills your credentials on
mobile sites and apps for iOS and
Android when you open an app or site
LastPass will fill in your username and
password for you making it fast and easy
to log in features include a limited
password storage free cross-device sync
and password sharing so click the link
below and start using LastPass today
thank you to LastPass for sponsoring
this portion of the video and now let's
get back to coding boot camps so first
let's talk about boot camps in 2020
according to a few market reports about
boot camps they have campuses in over 85
cities across the United States
and Canada 83% of boot camp grads report
being employed in programming jobs the
average starting salary is around sixty
seven thousand dollars across the United
States which varies a lot depending on
your location on average the tuition for
in-person boot camps is around thirteen
thousand five hundred dollars and there
are about fifteen weeks long and finally
online boot camps have seen enormous
growth of about one hundred and seventy
one percent which I imagine is even more
now because of covin 19 so our coding
bootcamp still a viable solution for
changing careers into technology well
the statistics show that the number of
boot camp graduates are increasing year
over year
so most boot camps really aren't going
anywhere anytime soon but on an
individual basis I learned that it
really depends on your personal
situation personally like I think it
comes down to opportunity cost I think
nowadays there's a lot of online
resources so if you're extremely
disciplined and maybe you've been doing
this for the last six months and you can
see yourself improving week over week
and month over month I would say go as
far as you can using online free
resources the biggest thing is to
consider is how do you get a job in tech
the quickest right so if you can do it
on your own using online resources great
that could be a great option for you
but if studying on your own is gonna
result in you spending 12 to 18 months
struggling you're probably better off
doing a part-time course or soft based
course that's six months long even if
you get a job three months quicker than
doing online that opportunity costs of
getting paid three months earlier will
already pay for itself so that's kind of
like I would think about like whether to
do it online for free or whether to sign
up for a boot camp if you're finding
yourself where you're getting stuck a
lot in those cases becomes do help
because they give you that structure you
also see other people around you
struggling which is actually I think
super underrated because when you're
learning on your own you might be
struggling you think you're the only
person that's having these issues and I
think that's also linked to the imposter
syndrome as well where you think this is
only happening to you but everyone else
around you is fully on top of their game
once you actually do a boot camp you
realize that everyone has a hard time
everyone struggles but that's part of
that journey so once you figure out
it's the right solution for you how do
you go about choosing which one to
attend well one of the most important
factors to consider is to think about
how you're going to sustain yourself
while you attend the bootcamp like
what's your lifestyle gonna be like do
you need to keep making income while
you're attending or do you have a
savings that you can lean on can you
afford your living expenses especially
if you're gonna move to a new city and
how many hours a week can you devote to
the bootcamp with a lot of folks in
Korea karma they're opting in for either
part-time or soft taste especially for
working adults very few people can take
three months off to just do bootcamp so
if you're gonna be doing a part-time
option figure out whether it's gonna be
nights and weekends or if it's gonna be
more soft based and flexible because
that's gonna make a difference if you're
gonna be signing out for the next six to
12 months to do bootcamp make sure that
you're not over stretching yourself and
especially if you have kids and family
you want to make sure that you're
balanced and you could actually complete
it and in talking a commitment like can
you actually commit to this doing this
bootcamp because I know there's a lot of
people in bootcamp they think they're
able to do it and then they come into
the bootcamp and they're like whoa this
is like a lot of work definitely if you
have the time then do it if you don't
have the time I would kind of reconsider
you will be spending a lot of late
nights doing doing a bunch of research
they're not there to teach you
everything they're there to teach you
how to get that information yeah how do
go is definitely like the number one
skill for bootcamp and one of the big
factors around this decision is to think
about what city you want to attend the
bootcamp in now I know we're kind of a
weird time because of kovin 19 but
pre-pandemic boot camps were most
plentiful in areas that have a tech hub
like San Francisco or New York City it's
not uncommon for people to move to these
tech hubs just to attend boot camps
since it's likely gonna be where they'll
find jobs too but for some a big move or
a commute to one might not make sense
are you able to like go out of your way
to like go to this boot camp like if
it's like an hour way but you look at
soaked out that's gonna be part of you
like two hours instead like this is
worth it for you is it worth it to drive
every day to your boot camp like can you
can you do that can you commit to that
so I looked at some other ones like hack
reactor general assembly the downside
with that one was it was too far for me
I live in
so cow traffic is like horrendous so I
didn't want to drive on it with la for a
hack reactor assembly or like Pomona so
that was kind of out of the question for
me but I learned interestingly that it
might be to your advantage to attend a
boot camp that's not in a tech hub what
we're finding is that people and
secondary like tech markets are actually
having an easier time finding a job
because there's less competition a lot
of companies are open to hiring junior
talent where's the main markets like San
Francisco New York LA Chicago there is
more saturation of but--can grads
looking for applying for jobs so then
you have to do more to stand out in your
interview processes another big factor
to consider which impacts your lifestyle
is the cost of the boot camp because
boot camps are not cheap they might
range anywhere from $2,000 to $30,000 so
a lot of people don't have that kind of
big money lying around but the good news
is each boot camp has different
offerings on how you can pay your gonna
always pay upfront and cash but there's
some creative financing options that
enable you to afford it without breaking
the bank one of the common ones is
deferred payments that's where you don't
need to pay the boot camp until you get
your first job
there's also income sharing where a boot
camp takes a percentage of maybe your
first one to three years worth of your
salary the cool things about income
sharing is that there's minimum salary
requirements so if you don't make above
a certain threshold you don't have to
pay even if you get your job most ice
say's have a maximum you'll out you'll
have to pay out and usually it's about
thirty thousand so for most schools
you're not gonna be more than 30k even
if you're making two hundred thousand as
your first job
but overall ask your boot terms of their
living stipends that's something that
has come up and if you live in Atlanta I
think San Francisco Denver you might be
eligible for some living stipend so Ice
Cube would camp up to have that tuition
for UCI you can do it multiple ways you
can pull out a loan you go through that
whole going process you have multiple
ways to pay off your loan and or you can
pay monthly you see guys program what's
around twelve thousand what I learned
from my other boot camp members was that
some of them already have like career
jobs and then some of their companies
are actually willing to it
than them be like hey if you want to do
this boot camp you can do it once you
complete it to show your certificate and
then we'll pay for like half of it
depending on what your starting salary
is if you choose something like income
sharing then it can determine how much
money you end up paying back to the boot
camp look at the market your end because
if you're in a competitive market and
there's a lot there are a lot of
companies hiring and maybe the average
salaries are like within the range where
even if you're paying back a percentage
of your income you're still gonna be in
a solid middle-class bracket I think
that makes sense but with some markets
if you're gonna be making a 50k or 55k
that's the average and then you have to
factor in that you're gonna be paying an
additional fifteen twenty percent income
sharing before tax that might be pretty
burdensome so you should definitely look
into your average salary rates when
you're evaluating the boot camps one
thing to note though if you choose the
financing option is that boot camps will
perform background and credit checks on
you to make sure that you can paint in
that if you're gonna be doing financing
which camps have different background
check requirements and credit history
requirements we recommend people to
apply to at least two or three different
schools there's folks that apply to one
school they're super excited and then
they get turned down because they have
maybe they have like a late theme and
I'm alone from six six years ago we tell
them not to give up because every school
has their own credit requirements and if
you don't get into one there's probably
at least one or two other boot camps
that will accept you now after you
figured out some of the big factors that
go into deciding a boot camp it's time
to do some more in-depth research to
find out what the actual experience will
be like you might be able to find a lot
of information on a boot camp website
but boot camp grads recommend that you
talk to past attendees to get the real
scoop on how it was doing your research
on these boot camps like understanding
what they give I've had a lot of people
reach out to me on LinkedIn like just
asking about the boot camp if you can't
find any more resources on the website
itself and reach out for people on
LinkedIn see if they put their school in
their LinkedIn just reach out them ask
them like hey like what do you think
about this boot camp do you think it was
worth it and then if you can't get more
information like just call the school
ask them like you know can I get a
curriculum can you give me more
information
really highly considering this I just
want more information and they'll more
than likely give you the information
they'll give you like for me they gave
me the curriculum and they went into
detail like this is what you've been
doing across these weeks and this is
what you're gonna learn if this is
something that you want to do this I
know that's why I mainly ask them you
know how was the job searching process
after attending the bootcamp yeah and I
asked him you know how long it took them
to find a job what it was like if they
bootcamp offered you any services for
help you know people were really open
about sharing their experiences so what
might you ask when you're talking to
past bootcamp grads well one important
thing could be job placement each
bootcamp may or may not offer some job
placement held after all the coursework
is done from resume reviews to
networking events to interview prep well
what's important is whether you're
actually able to land a job afterwards
at all a lot of my statistics I looked
up the kind of placement rates for those
specific boot camps and also average
salary coming out of those weekends
because I knew that if I was going to be
spending as much money I wanted to
definitely see results or maybe it's the
network and prestige that get you more
opportunities the other boot camps
around or vine to that I looked into but
it didn't seem like it was as
prestigious when I was talking to the
UCI person they're like yeah this is a
fairly new program but once you complete
it you're gonna be part of like the UCI
network which I am now cuz when you put
that on your on your LinkedIn a lot of
people are gonna like look you up from
Irvine and the last two factors to
consider are around learning styles each
boot camp runs our program a little
differently and hires their own
instructors to teach class some boot
cancer all online while others the
in-person we always recommend folks to
consider it like the teaching style and
your personal learning style and make
sure that that corresponds some folks
prefer in-person instruction some folks
are more free spirit and like to do
things remotely definitely like as
you're evaluating boot comes check out
if they have an online option available
or they have in-person only classes so
that's usually a big factor and while
most boot camps have some sort of
interview process to admit you into the
now some don't have a screening process
at all which means that anyone is
welcome but the coursework might not be
as rigorous as you want it to be a
downside with some of these boot camps
is there's no like screening process you
know I know certain programs they have a
screening process to do to see like are
you going to be able to do this with my
bootcamp Dera where there was no
screening process so we did have people
like they had no background in tech
whatsoever and they kind of just like
wanting to jump into this we kind of had
a cater to them a bit so like the pace
kind of slowed down and we couldn't
cover as much as we could don't get me
wrong like like it's it's totally cool
like there's just a downside cuz like
there are some of us in the boot camp
that are a little bit more advanced and
we wanted to really get like an
accelerated course and get to learn more
and more and more so there you have it
all the important factors on deciding
which boot camp to attend thank you to
our guests David Archer and Jason for
being on the channel and sharing your
experiences today if you attended a boot
camp then let me know what your
experiences have been and what advice
you have for others in cheesey a boot
camp in the comment section down below
don't forget to hit subscribe and I will
see you next time bye
[Music]